it's time now for CBS morning's deals
where we share some items that might
help make your day a little bit better
all at exclusive discounts to start
shopping now scan the QR code on your
screen go ahead and do it or visit
cbsdeals.com and we have Gail Bass the
host of lifestyle that means life and
style she does it all good I'm doing
good I'm doing good what isn't good is
the price of groceries these days it's a
lot and you don't want to be wasteful of
the food that you're buying and plus
when my doctor says you have to have
five fruits and vegetables a day right
you get a lot in the fridge that
eventually needs to be tossed out it's
true not with the Debbie Meyer green
boxes these are great because they're
designed and formulated to extend the
life of your fruits your veggies your
pastries they these are lab tested do
they work on bananas yes they do work on
bananas but they hear here's what they
say they say if you leave your cookies
in there for 42 days those cookies will
last 42 days unless my Brian's in the
house they'll last 42 minutes
but these are wonderful and you know we
have uh we have a deal on these you can
get 16 boxes that's 32 pieces tops and
lid bottoms and lids for
18.88. did you get all of those you get
all of these and you know what and
they're different sizes they are
different sizes so whether you have
shortened carrots you have cherries go
to cbsdeals.com right now because these
are very popular these are going to want
to sell out when people start eating
healthy go into farmers markets getting
those fruits that you want to extend the
life of this and just preserving your
food in general right oh yeah or or for
me safety pins yeah there's no doubt
about it the other thing is they're
light yes
they're dishwasher safe and microwave
yeah the Daphne power I love this I
talked to the creator of this yesterday
is their name Daphne no her name is not
Daphne but what's really great is that
she said I have hair like Hagrid and
Harry Potter and she also has four
children and she's an engineer she says
there's got to be a better way for me to
take care of my hair than just putting
it through flat iron with with heat
elements on both sides so she and her
dad created the Daphne power which is a
styling brush here you can see it being
used on two types of different hair
where women can take bigger lumps of
their hair bigger a bigger handful of
hair and bring it through their hair and
get that straighter smoother look give
it a little twist if you want this
shorter brush this is the the smaller
brush can be used for shorter finer hair
how do you do this Gale without it being
all tangled up in your hair and you have
to cut it out well women which I've seen
done before Gail if you can brush your
hair you can use the Daphne power and
women who've used it and other people
who've used it have said they've gone
from 30 minutes to five minutes think
about that cutting down that model is
doing a little twisty thing you have to
re-emphasize two different types of hair
yeah is it common with some of these
products that are out on the market
right right that separates yes the
medium to full shorter finer thinner and
this starts at 91 dollars will this work
on black here yes we had we both had an
example I didn't see yeah I use the
turbine it may comb through a lot easier
because this is sometimes be a little
tough right here we have the bling stain
okay I love this this is a personal
safety alarm this is great to give your
mom to give your kids when they're going
off to college and as you can see this
is small like an earphone case you know
it's very small it's unobtrusive people
aren't going to think hey that's a
safety device now I'm going to show you
how easily this works now I need to warn
you this does get very loud 125 decibels
but easy to deploy
just like that you can hear it this this
right here on the front that's a speaker
that is the speaker on the front it's on
the bottom and you will not accidentally
uh deploy that is a great Father's Day
gift Father's Day speaking of fun to his
yeah his daughter yes or his son or his
wife or anybody anybody fifteen to
sixteen dollars all right and speaking
of Father's Day all of this to me says
dad's drinking in the basement with the
home bar right this is decoration okay
you know what this is decoration I
talked to the founder yesterday and he
said these vintage style signs are very
popular they're made of galvanized
welcome to Big Daddy's full service what
does that mean Nate it means
[Laughter]
okay sorry these have LED lights they're
battery operated uh and they're ready to
be placed on the wall what I love is
that they give you this retro vintage
feel I'm vintage I'm vintage 1969. yeah
some people go back a little bit farther
you can make dads man cave his office
his his shed those are her she shed
because they have a couple of signs I
want to grab for myself but these are a
great idea to treat dad for Father's Day
and we have them starting at
29.99 oh that comes with the spare light
always good that's it yeah yeah right
there all right Gail bass thank you we
appreciate you of course we partnered
with all these companies to get these
deals to buy anything that you saw scan
the QR code on your screen or head over
to cbsdeals.com to start shopping now